leading us Democratic presidential
candidate Joe Biden has defended himself
after coming under so-called friendly
fire from his own party they claim he's
been too sympathetic towards racial
segregation in the past it's so easy to
go back and go back 30 40 50 years and
take a context and take it completely
out of context and I mean you know I I
get all this information about other
people's past and what they've done and
not done and you know I'm just not gonna
go there if we keep doing that that's I
mean what was she debated what we do
from here the issue of racial
segregation was raised late in June
during the first Democratic Party debate
ahead of the 2020 presidential election
but Nexus morning as Kelly mopin
explains throughout American history the
Democrats haven't always been so Pro
integration Joe Biden the current
frontrunner and the Democratic
presidential race has come forward to
apologize about statements he made about
working with advocates of racial
segregation I regret it
I'm sorry Freddie the pain or
misconception they may have caused
anybody earlier Joe Biden made
statements about his previous work with
segregationists he was almost nostalgic
saying he got things done with some
civility now his apology comes as his
rivals have been taking him to task over
his record I don't think you have to be
touting personal relationship with
people who were very brutal
segregationist it was hurtful to hear
you talk about the reputations of two
United States senators who built their
reputations and career on the
segregation of race in this country now
Joe Biden is still in the lead despite
the scandal however it seems to have
unearthed a strange reality in American
politics the Democratic Party the party
that brought us the first African
American president has a rather strange
record when it comes to the issue of
racism when Senator Robert Byrd West
Virginia died Barack Obama gave him a
stirring eulogy he was a Senate icon
he was a party leader he was an elder
statesman and he was my friend
that's how I'll remember him prior to
becoming a US Senator Robert Byrd had
been a high-ranking member of the Ku
Klux Klan
afterwards he repudiated the views of
the hate group but prior to that he had
some strong views when it came to the
issue of race
I shall never fight in the armed forces
with the negro by my side rather I
should die a thousand times and see old
glory trampled in the dirt never to rise
again than to see this beloved land of
ours become degraded by race mongrels a
throwback to the blackest specimen from
the wilds Bill Clinton who was wildly
popular among African Americans gave a
eulogy when he was president for J
William Fulbright another Democrat we
come to celebrate and give thanks for
the remarkable life of J William
Fulbright a life that changed our
country and our world forever and for
the better
well the glowing words left out the fact
that Fulbright was a big advocate of
keeping black and white children in
separate schools back in the 1960s when
John F Kennedy and the northern
democratic party organizations located
in urban areas were pushing for racial
integration the biggest pushback didn't
come from Republicans it came from the
Dixiecrats a splinter group within their
own party in 1968 George Wallace the
Democratic governor of Alabama was so
outraged to see anti racism become the
dominant view within his own party that
he ran as a third-party candidate then
you ought to come on down to Alabama we
would keep you some low down there
but now it would seem that a Democrat
having such an agenda would be almost
unbelievable in fact MSNBC mislabeled
George Wallace as a Republican check it
out
Governor George Wallace stood outside
the University of Alabama personally
blocking to black students from
enrolling there Joe Biden has come
forward and apologized for his
statements on racial matters but it
seems like the country has forgotten but
not so long ago his entire party had the
same issue after the Civil War was the
Democratic Party that was the racist it
was the Republican Party that was
different
that Republicans were anti-slavery
Lincoln was Republican anti-slavery it
changed the Dixiecrats after segregation
after the Civil War they were the racist
everything was a mess we've had
presidents Supreme Court justices who
were members of the Klan some of them
had to do that to join the Ku Klux Klan
for political reasons I don't understand
why this now with body
you